.
THE OBAMA ECONOMIC NIGHTMARE IS
OVER.
SIT TIGHT.
IT'S BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
MICHAEL HOROWITZ COMPLETED HIS
REPORT DETAILING HOW JAMES AND
OTHER AND TOP FBI OFFICIALS
HANDLE THE CRIMINAL CASE AGAINST
HARMED.
5 -- HILLARY CLINTON.
500 PEOPLE ON HIS TEAM.
THEY ARE BEING STALLED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THE SAME PEOPLE OBSTRUCTING
CONGRESS AND RESPONSIBLE FOR
REDACTING AND IGNORING
SUBPOENAED DOCUMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WHO ARE
TRYING TO DO THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY OF OVERSIGHT
AS REQUIRED BY THE CONSTITUTION.
EVERY AMERICAN TONIGHT NEED TO
BE DEMANDING THIS REPORT IS
RELEASED IN FULL RIGHT NOW.
DON'T BURY IS THIS THURSDAY OR
FRIDAY LEADING INTO THE TRUMP
SUMMIT.
EARLIER THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
THIS.
WHAT HAS TAKEN SO LONG WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT ON
CROOKED HILLARY CLINTON:
SARAH CARTER IS SHINING HUGE
LIGHT ON THIS REPORT WHY THE
IGREPORT IS NOT RELEASED.
AND THE IG IS PRESSURED TO DELIE
THEIR FINDINGS AND THEY WANT TO
RELEASE IT ON THE WEEKEND
HEADING INTO THE BIG SUMMIT WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM JONG-UN.
SHE WROTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND FBI ARE ATTEMPTING
TO SLOW ROLL THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S RESPECT.
SOME ARE CONCERNED THAT THE DOJ
IS PLANNING TO BURY THIS REPORT
ON FRIDAY LEADING INTO NEXT
WEEK'S SUMMIT.
YOU THE PUBLIC HAVE A RIGHT TO
SEE THIS INFORMATION.
THIS HAS TAKEN 18 MONTHS!
THEY CAN'T BURY THIS.
THEY CANNOT ALTER THIS.
THEY CAN'T REDACT THIS.
IT SEEMS TO BE SLOW WALKED.
AND TRYING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
DO TO TAKE OUT THE IMPORTANT
FINDINGS HERE.
OUR QUESTIONS DESERVE TO BE
ANSWERED.
WHERE IS THE REPORT ON THE
TARMAC MEETING BETWEEN BILL
CLINTON AND LORETTA LYNCH?
THE REPORT ON JAMES COMEY
WRITING EXXON
WRITING EXXO
WRITING EXON
WRITING EXONER
WRITING EXONERAT
WRITING EXONERATIO
WRITING EXONERATION
WRITING EXONERATION O
WRITING EXONERATION ON
WRITING EXONERATION ON H
WRITING EXONERATION ON HIL
WRITING EXONERATION ON HILLA
WRITING EXONERATION ON HILLARY
CLINTON IN MAY BEFORE HE
INTERVIEWED HER AND 17 OTHER KEY
WITNESSES?
WHERE IS THE REPORT ON WHY THE
FBI LOOKED THE OTHER WAY AS
HILLARY CLINTON DESTROYED
EVIDENT DELETING 33,000 EMAILS
AND ACID WASHED HER HARD DRIVE.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE DOJ.
THEY DECLINED TO COMMENT.
THE FIX WAS IN FOR HILLARY
CLINTON AND HOW HILLARY CLINTON
COMMITTED FELONIES, WE HAVE NEW
INFORMATION SURROUNDING FORMER
NAVY SAILOR CHRISTIAN.
REMEMBER HIM?
HE WAS NOT GIVEN ANY SPECIAL
HILLARY CLINTON TREATMENT.
HILLARY CLINTON MISHANDLED TOP
SECRET INFORMATION ON HER
PRIVATE EMAIL AND LIE ABOUT IT
ALL.
NO CHARGES AGAINST HER.
POOR CHRISTIAN TOOK 6 PICTURES
ON A SUBMARINE HE WAS PROUD TO
WORK ON AND NEVER PUT THEM IN
THE PUBLIC.
HE WAS PUT IN PRISON FOR A YEAR.
HE IS SUING PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
JAMES COMEY SAYING HE WAS
SUBJECTED TO UNEQUAL PROTECTION
UNDER THE LAW.
THAT SOUNDS RIGHT SADLY.
THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE FBI
ANDREW McCABE WAS FIRED FOR
LYING.
HASN'T BEEN CHARGED WITH ANY
CRIME.
THERE IS A CRIMINAL REFERRAL.
McCABE IS ASKING FOR IMMUNITY IN
EXCHANGE FOR HIS TESTIMONY IN
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
IT'S THE YEAR OF THE BOOMERANG.
THIS IS A CIRCLULAR FIRING
SQUAD.
MORE IN A MOMENT.
FIRST WE HAVE SOME NOT SO
SHOCKING NEWS ABOUT SO-CALLED
JOURNALISM IN AMERICA.
LOOK AT THIS NEW POLL FROM THE
PUGH RESEARCH CENTER.
70% OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
NEWS FATIGUE.
JUST MAYBE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE TIRED OF THE MEDIA'S
OBSESSIVE, COMPULSIVE HYSTERIA
SURROUNDING THEIR NEWS COVERAGE
AND FALSE PANIC OVER NORTH KOREA
AND NUCLEAR WAR AND COLLUSION
WITH NO EVIDENCE AND NOW FALSE
PANIC OVER A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP DECLARES HE
HAS THE POWER TO PARDON HIMSELF.
UNLEASHING NEW FEARS ABOUT HIS
RESPONSE TO THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
>> WE ARE HEADING INTO A
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
>> WE HEAR THAT PHRASE REPEATED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> IT'S GIVES THE PRESIDENT THE
ABSOLUTE POWER THAT RAISES THE
QUESTION OF A CRISIS.
>> THIS IS THE KIND OF
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS EXPERTS
HAVE BEEN WARNING ABOUT.
SEAN WHEN DOES IT CROSS OVER.
THEY DON'T DO THEIR WORK AND
THEY TRY TO OUT-RAGE EACH OTHER.
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF THE
ANTI-TRUMP STANCE EVERY DAY.
LIKE THIS ONE FROM APRIL RYAN.
WATCH PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
SANDERS RESPOND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IS THE PRESIDENT AWARE --
>> SORRY, GO AHEAD.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> IS THE PRESIDENT AWARE THAT
TAKING THE KNEE IS ABOUT POLICE
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS?
>> THE PRESIDENT MADE HIS
POSITION CRYSTAL CLEAR.
I LET YOU RUDELY INTERRUPT ME
AND YOUR COLLEAGUES.
I ASK THAT YOU ALLOW ME TO
FINISH YOUR ANSWER.
I WOULD ANSWER IT IF YOU STOP
TALKING LONG ENOUGH TO LET ME DO
THAT.
THE PRESIDENT MADE HIS POSITION
CRYSTAL CLEAR ON THIS TOPIC.
HE FEELS STRONGLY THAT STANDING
FOR THE NATIONAL ANTHEM IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD DO.
THE PRESIDENT WON'T BACK DOWN
FROM IT.
APRIL, I ADDRESSED YOUR
QUESTION.
I WON'T CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
YOU.
>> WILL THE PRESIDENT DEAL WITH
THE ISSUE OF POLICE INVOLVED
SHOOTING?
>> I WILL DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF
ADDRESSING YOUR COLLEAGUES
QUESTION.
>> Sean: MAYBE YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF THE MEDIA
NASTY PERSONAL ATTACKS INCLUDING
COVERAGE OF OUR FIRST LADY
MELANIA TRUMP.
FOLLOWING A MEDICAL PROCEDURE
FOR A KIDNEY CONDITION.
SHE WAS ONLY SEEN ONCE IN THE
PUBLIC SPOTLIGHT.
LEAVING SOME IN THE PRESSRUNING
WILD WITH INSANE SPECULATION
WITH SOME OF THE NASTIEST
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THIS WRITER TWEETED THAT I WISH
I DIDN'T SUSPECT IT WAS ABOUT
CONCEALING ABUSE.
I WISH THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT:
THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS AND
DISGUSTING.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
LOOK AT DAVID, A NEVER-TRUMP
TWEETING:
THE PRESIDENT HAS ARTICLE 2
AUTHORITY OVER THE SECRET
SERVICE.
IS THAT OBSTRUCTION?
THIS CONTINUED EACH ON
TELEVISION.
THIS IS HOW INSANE OUR MEDIA HAS
BECOME.
THIS IS A MASS PSYCHOSIS THAT
KICKED IN ABOUT 10 P.M. NOVEMBER
8th, 2016, WHEN THE PERSON THEY
THOUGHT WOULD NEVER WIN WON BY A
BIG MARGIN.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE WONDERING
WHERE THE FIRST LADY IS THESE
DAYS.
DROPPED OUT OF SIGHT SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN HER SINCE THE
10th.
AND EVERYONE HAS THEIR QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHERE IS SHE?
>> THE LAST TIME WAS ON MAY
10th.
24 DAYS.
MORE THAN 3 WEEKS.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT HER
SURGERY.
HER TIME AT WALTER REED.
HOW LONG DOES SHE HAVE TO BE OUT
OF SIGHT TO MAKE THIS A
LEGITIMATE MEDIA STORY?
>> FIRST LADIES GET MEDIA
COVERAGE.
WHEN A FIRST LADY DISAPPEARS
FROM THE PUBLIC SCENE 24 DAYS
AFTER BEING IN THE HOSPITAL, OF
COURSE REPORTERS ARE RAISING
QUESTIONS.
>> THE FIRST LADY HAS BEEN SEEN
IN PUBLIC FOR 25 DAYS.
I AM NOT SURPRISED.
IT TOOK THAT SHAW SHANK GUY
YEARS TO TUNNEL OUT.
>> Sean: THIS IS SO DESPICABLE.
4 LAST WEEK SAW MELANIA TRUMP
AND SAID NOTHING.
I HAVE SOURCES CONFIRMING.
SHE HAD AN OPERATION.
MAYBE WISHING HER WELL IS THE
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE.
THE FIRST LADY RESPONDED ON
TWITTER, WRITING:
WOULD THAT SHUT THEM OUT?
PROBABLY NOT.
ANOTHER ANTI-TRUMP NONSTORY.
ABOUT THE PHILADELPHIA EAGLES
BEING DISINVITED TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AFTER THE BIG SUPER BOWL
VICTORY.
SARAH SANDERS RESPONDED.
>> 80 MEMBERS OF THE EAGLES
COMMITED TO ATTEND THIS EVENT AS
RECENTLY AS FRIDAY AS WELL AS
OVER 1,000 FANS FROM THE EAGLES
ORGANIZATION.
THE EAGLES ARE THE ONES THAT
TRIED TO CHANGE THEIR COMMITMENT
AT THE 11th HOUR.
THE PRESIDENT THINKS THE FANS
DESERVE BETTER THAN THAT.
THIS WAS NOT A POLITICAL STUNT
BY THE EAGLES FRANCHISE.
THEN THEY WOULD HAVE PLANED TO
ATTEND AND BACKED OUT AT THE
LAST-MINUTE AND WOULD NOT HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO RE-SCHEDULE THE
VISIT WHEN THEY KNEW THE
PRESIDENT WAS GOING TO BE
OVERSEAS.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE WAITED UNTIL
MONDAY AFTER OVER 1,000 OF THEIR
FANS TOOK TIME OFF OF THEIR
SCHEDULE TO ATTEND THE EVENT.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT
TO CANCEL THIS EVENT.
BY THE WAY, LOOK AT THE NFL
TODAY.
LOOK AT THE NEW RULE REQUIRING
PLAYERS TO STAND OR GO HIDE IN
THE LOCKER ROOM.
THE OWNER OF THE NEW YORK JET
OFFERED TO PAY THE FINES FOR ANY
PLAYER THAT PROTESTS THE ANTHEM.
I HAVE HAD IT.
I AM SUPPOSED TO TUNE INTO A
FOOTBALL GAME AND WATCH PEOPLE
WHO MAKE A LOT OF MONEY MAKING A
STATEMENT.
NOT THE EAGLES IN THIS CASE.
BUT THEY MADE A POLITICAL
STATEMENT REGARDING THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THE FLAG IS HONORING MEN AND
WOMEN WHO DIED FOR THEIR COUNT
REACH.
LOOK WHAT ROGER GOODELL AND
OTHER NFL OWNERS HAVE DONE.
I AM DONE WITH THE NFL.
I LIKE COLLEGE FOOTBALL.
UNLESS MEMBERS OF THE NATIONAL
FOOTBALL LEAGUE GAIN THE RESPECT
FOR THE FLAG AND THOSE WHO BLED
AND DIED FIGHTING UNDER THAT
TODAY THE PRESIDENT HOSTED A
CELEBRATION FEATURING THE MARINE
BAND AND AMERICANS HAVE SO MUCH
TO CELEBRATE INCLUDING THE
BOOMING ECONOMY.
WOW!
SO DIFFERENT THAN JUST 501 DAYS
AGO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> OUR COUNTRY HAS NEVER DONE
BETTER THAN IT'S DOING RIGHT
NOW.
NEVER!
RECORD NUMBERS IN EVERY OUTPOST.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING ON.
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS WE
HAVE HAD.
LOWEST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT IN THE HISTORY OF
OUR COUNTRY.
LOWEST HISPANIC NUMBERS IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
LOWEST NUMBERS FOR WOMEN IN 21
YEARS.
WE HAVE CREATED 7 TRILLION
DOLLARS OF VALUE IN OUR COUNTRY
SINCE THE ELECTION.
WE ARE THE LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD AND GETTING A LOT
LARGER AND FAST.
IT'S HAPPENED VERY QUICKLY.
ACTUALLY, QUICKER THAN I EVEN
THOUGHT.
>> Sean: ONLY FIRST1 DAYS.
-- ONLY 501 DAYS.
BAD NEWS FOR THE CORRUPT MEDIA
BECAUSE THEY WANT THE PRESIDENT
TO FAIL.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY TRUMP AT
ANY COST.
HIM BEING SUCCESSFUL IS NOT GOOD
TOWARDS THAT GOAL.
THEIR LITTLE EGOS CAN REMAIN
INTACT AND THEIR FRIENDS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE HOPING TO
REGAIN POWER.
THAT'S WHY THIS MID-TERM
ELECTION IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
IN OUR LIFETIME.
THAT WON'T STOP THE PRESIDENT'S
ECONOMIC POLICIES FROM VASTLY
IMPROVING THIS COUNTRY.
REMEMBER THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND
WOMEN.
NOW THE ATLANTA FED IS
PREDICTING THE ECONOMY WILL GROW
AT 4.8%.
COMPARE THIS TO THE 8 YEARS OF
OBAMA.
THEY TOLD US 1% GROWTH WAS THE
NEW NORMAL FOR THE UNITED STATES
AND WE SHOULD ACCEPT IT.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER.
13 MILLION MORE AMERICANS UNDER
FOOD STAMPS UNDER OBAMA.
THE WORST RECOVERY SINCE THE
'40s.
THE LOWEST HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE IN
51 YEARS AND THE DOUBLING OF OUR
NATIONAL DEBT THAT PRESIDENT
OBAMA SAID IRRESPONSIBLE.
THANK GOD THE ERA OF FAILURE
UNDER OBAMA IS OVER AND
AMERICA'S ECONOMY IS AFTER 501
DAYS OF TRUMP BOOMING.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN: